unions are they a net negative to
society or net positive to society I
asked us on Twitter a lot of people say
Pat unions are bad they're terrible look
what they're doing to Hollywood we're
writers and actors being on strikes
since May since July hey look what great
job unions are doing for their employees
look at UPS they got 30 billion dollars
now on average full-time employee at UPS
makes 49 bucks an hour that's a hundred
and one thousand dollar a year income
unions are fantastic so I said listen
let's take a look Pros cons biggest
unions in America politically which way
do they give their money we looked at
every single election all the way back
to 2010 to see how it looks we looked at
union leaders what kind of money do
these guys make how much the actual
membership costs and last but not least
I just watched them with the Oppenheimer
was a three-hour movie honestly I think
they could have gone on a strike for
about an hour of that movie but anyways
I watched the movie three major Union
Leader names I'll give you one of them I
think you know who it is the other two
you're gonna be like that guy was a
union leader they were having said that
let's take a deep dive in minutes
thank you
foreign
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel let's get right into a couple
things we need to know pros and cons by
unions and what it costs number one the
cost of being part of a union is around
one percent to four percent of your
salary if you make 50 Grand a year it
could be 500 up to two thousand dollars
of your salary to be a member now why do
some people join unions and why do
people say keep it away from me because
about 10.3 percent of employees in
America are part of Union here's the
pros and cons pros employees who are
part of a union typically make more
money than those who are not number two
safety protections three job security
for a sense of community five promoting
equality six protection from unfair
dismissal cons decrease flexibility that
means if everybody goes on a strike you
have to go on a strike because you're
part of Union which means you're going
to get paid while you're on a strike so
you could go a week two weeks three
weeks if you're a writer right now it's
almost nine ten weeks you ain't getting
paid for not doing work because you're
part of a union so you can't work while
you're part of it so that's part of the
mandatory strike adversarial work Place
relations which means you're kind of
like working out of place and you're not
supposed to like your boss and your boss
doesn't trust you because if they talk
about everything you may go tell the
unions they may come after them they're
walking on eggshells the Dynamics kind
of change because you're working with
your boss where he's kind of part of the
enemy it's like well you know we
shouldn't do union he doesn't feel
comfortable talking to you and you're
kind of like well I don't know if I
should tell the union what's going on
but I kind of want to work here but who
cares they're not going to fire me and
it was kind of like being out of DMV say
whatever I want to I don't care what
they're going to say about me I'm
protected here number three is union
dues number four is potential for
corruption five seniority over
performance you could be the best
working person there but no it's about
10 years they reward tenure and how long
you've been around over somebody that's
really driven to want to compete which
it attracts people that want to stick
around just give average return for work
because many times if I do too good of a
work then my expectation increases so
the competitive people almost always
don't want to be part of a union and
last but not least the consumer the
buyer takes a hit because every time
they raise prices for pay the way that
company's gonna make up for that expense
is they have to raise their prices so
you the consumer that not part of a
union you're not paying higher prices so
it kind of messes up the company but it
hurts the consumer which is you so now
let's take a look at what are the
biggest unions we have in America number
one National Education Association of
the United States Nea total membership
over 3 million this is Public School
Employees including but not limited to
teachers education support professionals
cafeteria workers bus drivers etc etc
number two service employees
International Union around 1.9 1 million
memberships this is Hotel Restaurant
Hospitality workers RNs professionals
etc etc number three American Federation
of teachers it's a different Union for
teachers around 1.67 million Public
School teachers registered nurses
professionals and others number four
International Brotherhood of teamsters
Jimmy Hoffa truck drivers warehouse
workers and other trades number five
American Federation of state and County
and Municipal Employees total
memberships 1.3 million this is
employees of state county and Municipal
governments so now somebody may be
watching this if you're part of a union
you may be like well screw you Pat I
like my union cool no problem good for
you but somebody may say listen I don't
want to be part of Union I don't want
you to control how much I can move up I
want to move up faster than you dictated
my speed I don't want to be part of you
yeah that's why 10.3 Americans are part
of Union that's why 90 or not most of
Americans are like I want to dictate my
growth up but let's look at these union
leaders these Noble union leaders let's
see what kind of money they make now
keep in mind in America the highest
position in America is a president
commander-in-chief okay we have a man
there right now called Joseph he gets
paid 400 000 per year this President
Joseph Biden makes four hundred thousand
dollars per year let's see how his
salary the leader of the Free World
matches to the salary of somebody's
union leaders the great Taryn Sullivan
General president of laborers National
headquarters makes
981. number two Patrick Flynn this is
the treasurer or the main leader of
teamsters his salary five hundred and
three thousand dollars Newton B Jones
president of International Brotherhood
of boy makers 491 thousand dollars
Joseph senes executive director of
national production workers union he
makes around 487. then you have Michael
Sweeney who was the president earlier I
talked about Patrick Flynn who was the
secretary treasurer but Michael Sweeney
the president of teamsters makes 387
slightly less than the president and
then we can go to others James Hoffa he
was making 381 we can go to a bunch of
different names but these union leaders
make pretty good money some of them make
more money than the president now some
of you may say Pat what's the big deal
Elon Musk is worth 300 billion dollars
who cares if he's making 600 I'm just
comparing a government employee union
versus the highest ranking government
employee that's their choice President
Biden could have gone into free market
and tried to compete he could have done
that would have made a lot more money
but if you choose to be a public
government employee that position the
highest position only pays 400. these
union leaders are making some real good
money for a union employee so next I
said listen let's just try to see you
know where the money goes is there any
kind of political gamification and this
thing obviously none of these guys are
going to be dirty people they're noble
people they're Fair people they're
probably going to be right in the middle
on the way they give their money half
Republican half Democrat that's how it's
got to be right I mean they're going to
be fair folks that we're dealing with so
here's what it looks like 2022 election
cycle Dems versus Republicans when it
comes down to public sector unions top
contributors to Federal candidates
parties or outside groups it was a total
contribution of 83 million dollars give
or take party breakdown 90 percent
Democrats 10 percent Republicans but
that's 90 10. so now it's going to
change of course if we go further back
it's probably going to be closer to 50
let's go to 2020. okay 2020 Dems versus
Republicans total contributions 93
million dollars a little over that 89
Democrats and you got 11 percent
Republicans okay so so that's two of
them in a row election cycle that's
around 90 10 rule but maybe it's going
to change if we go to 2018. 2018 total
contributions 56 million dollars 87
Democrats 13 Republicans fair enough so
now Republicans are kind of making some
progress the more we go backwards let's
look at in 2016. 66 million dollars
ready 90 Democrats 10 percent Republican
let's go to 2014. 54 million dollars
ready 92 percent Democrats only eight
percent Republicans it's going to change
eventually right 2012. 44 million
dollars 92 Democrats eight percent
Republican let's go to 2010. 25 million
dollars 91 Democrats nine percent
Republicans let's go to two thousand
maybe change it up a little bit 93
Democrats 7 Republican do you think
maybe unions are necessary because
they're protected by a political party
that's getting them the votes and the
money I don't know I'm just simply
reading you reports you can go do the
research yourself as well but this is
what the data tells us now to be fair
it's very easy for me to show you
reports that only you know maybe favors
one side of the argument not the other
side let's look at Gallup on whether
they approve or disapprove of labor
unions the percentage has got to be high
that disapproves right I bet 80 doesn't
improve or approve or 70 percent maybe 9
90 doesn't approve but it's actually the
other way around 71 of Americans as of
2021 approve of labor unions and it's
been around that same number since the
30s so if 71 approves why is it only
10.3 percent of employees in America are
part of unions let's take a look at this
so most companies will do everything
they can in their power to fight off
unionization but there are strict laws
against that called union busting like
Amazon Starbucks apple locations right
now like some of the employees are like
well we should do it we shouldn't do it
no we should do it and the guys at the
top are like listen we do not want to be
a union company so there's a back and
forth fight that's going on there but
Union momentum always increases when
times are difficult the Great Depression
led to the New Deal which created
several laws empowering unions and the
National Labor Union was the first
attempt in U.S to organize a national
Federation of Labor when labor groups
met in Baltimore beginning on August
20th 1866 this is an economic
perspective on the change to an
eight-hour day back in the days you
could work a lot more than eight hours
and it's a this is too much we got to
get people working less so now let me
give you an ideal profile of somebody
likes being part of a union you don't
want to work a lot you want somebody to
dictate your value and you want to be
able to not give your best at a job and
still get a steady raise and you know
you can talk back to your boss and who
cares they can't fire you because of
tenure and you know nowadays good luck
trying to fire a teacher there's
teachers that have done some really
really bad stuff because it's terrible
stuff you can read about but they can't
get fired because the union protects
them so you may say but I like that
that's kind of gives me safety no
problem but the profile of people that
don't like unions again are those I want
to say I dictate my future for myself
just like the Gallup poll we ran no one
should be surprised that anybody that
gets entitlement programs is going to
say I support entitlement programs
nobody's going to complain of anything
that's being given to them freely to say
no no this isn't good stuff keep sending
it my way because I want more of these
free programs so there's a profile for
people who like being part of the Union
but let me give you an idea I earlier I
talked about Hollywood what's going on
with them you know the SAG the writers
let me give you an idea what happens
when you're part of Union what you can't
do for example there's a lot of guests
that we were about to have on a podcast
you know what they responded back with I
cannot be on your podcast why not one of
them is a very very famous conservative
actor email back I can't work because
I'm part of the union and you know who
disguise but let me tell you what you
can't do when you're part of a union in
Hollywood acting singing dancing
performance stunts piloting on camera
aircraft puppeteering performance
capture Motion Picture work ADR looping
TV trailers theatrical trailers voice
acting singing narration stunt
coordinating and related Services
background work stand-in work photo or
body doubles fitting wardrobe tests and
makeup tests rehearsals camera test
scanning interviews and auditions
promotional publicity services for
workers under the TV and Theatrical
contract such as tours personal pre
nurses interviews conventions fan Expos
festivals for your consideration events
panels Premiere screenings award shows
junkets podcast appearances social media
Studio showcases they can't go on a pack
podcast how crazy is that so if you like
being controlled by the union it's the
perfect type of a membership if it fits
your profile but if you like to be free
and dictate your terms and you're going
to say I decide how much I get paid
because I'm going to bust my toe then
you're not going to need a union so like
we just looked at Hollywood what that
looks like if you're part of sag or
writer's Guild all that stuff but how
about another industry Auto industry
Detroit was the place all these
automakers were there and then all of a
sudden Union came and destroyed a once
great City Dearborn I've been there I
saw what happened there are
conversations with a lot of people but
watch what happened with these guys
foreign automakers enter the U.S market
in 1970 and hired non-union workers to
build Vehicles due to the savings and
labor costs they could afford to sell
their vehicles for less than U.S
manufacturers this made it much harder
for unionized big three automakers to
produce competitive cars at affordable
prices and they lost significant market
share so so obviously in 1970 some of
these guys can get away with the Toyota
Nissan these companies for decades got
away with it and then all of a sudden
like no no no no boom we got to get
these companies Chokehold get them
unionized they did guess who's the only
automaker in America today that's not
unionized you want to take a while yes
it's one of the most hated guys in the
world he's evil he just bought a company
and changed the name to ex how dare he
do something like that Tesla is the only
one that's not an FYI Philip Morris got
a very high score ESG with a plus all
this stuff Tesla got a very low score
because Tesla's ESG score is bad they're
bad people at Tesla what Elon Musk is
doing you get the idea what's going on
here non-union Union how much longer you
think until they get a figure hold of
these guys to say we got to make Tesla
Union as well I don't know but if the
history tells us the way they've been
handling things eventually it's going to
happen to them as well unless everyone
fights it off last but not least let's
take a look at the history of unions in
America 1768 first record of all workers
strike 1794 Philadelphia shoemakers
formed the First Union in 1835 black
cocker held a strike at Washington Navy
Yard 1866 National Labor Union was
created 1867 National Union for cigar
makers became First Union to accept
women in Blacks 1867 2 000 Chinese
workers on Transcontinental Railroad
protested lower pay 1913 Department of
Labor DOL was created 1914 Clayton
Anti-Trust enacted 1979 we had 21
million union members and 2021 non-union
workers had median weekly earnings that
were 83 percent of earnings of union
members you see that stat right there
that stat gets people to say well if I'm
part of Union I'm going to make more
money right yes if you are not planning
to compete above and beyond everybody
else if you see yourself as a limited
person with limited capacity you could
join the union but if you see yourself
as somebody that can improve with access
to all this education that's out there
you're like no I don't have a limit on
how much I can grow then no problem
Union is not for you now if we look at
union leaders like if you were to talk
about the first one it would be Samuel
Gompers who was the first and longest
serving president of American Federation
of Labor AFL so him this was like 1881
to around 1913 whatever the time
somewhere around that time frame that he
has lasted for a long time so some
people may say well listen if you're a
union leader for 30 years don't you like
become like a powerful figure like
almost like a mob boss sometimes because
if we look at the history of people that
became union leaders a guy named Jimmy
Hoffa you want to know another one
another guy named Stalin you want
another one outside of Stalin Castro
Castro was a union leader now you may
say Pat you're just picking the evil
ones and the bad ones I'm not doing it
I'm just telling you who was before what
they did when they got a lot of power
and a lot of control and next thing you
know a lot of Havoc happen so yeah maybe
it's good in some cases maybe it's good
if the government's not involved maybe
it's good if you're not paying this much
money to a political party I mean you
get some stories that comes out October
1st 2020 11 Union officials charged with
racketeering fraud and bribery offenses
you would think this is from 40 years
years ago with some of them are being
connected to it it's not this is just
2020 that came out from a southern
district of New York and we can go
through a lot of different stories I
think the intentions starts off good if
there's no term limits and you can stay
there for too long there is no
difference between a union leader and a
person in Congress that's been there for
30 40 50 years it's a membership you're
getting away with doing whatever you
want to do you become some of the most
powerful people it's those people that
say stuff like ah a president is only
four years we're going to be here for
four years don't worry about it God's
Gonna Come and Go it becomes about power
and that's what concerns the other 90
that doesn't yet want to be part of a
union so if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel and if you didn't watch
the video in regards to the strike in
Hollywood there's some crazy data on
that click here to watch that video take
care everybody bye-bye bye-bye
foreign